today is Toby flanderson's last day I
couldn't sleep last night I came in
extra early so much energy there's
certain days that you know you will
remember for the rest of your life and I
just have a feeling that today is one of
those days
I have no idea how you
how you sit like that yoga
sit on floor and put together a chair we
will
Yoda
um
it started
[Laughter]
poly flax
marrying me will you be
your wife be coming he will I
hey I heard you got a wedding dress do
you have pictures oh I yeah um I'll show
them to you later
out
that's my dress
do I just going to hand out index cards
and I want you all to write down the
name of an eligible woman for me to date
by the end of the day
no by the end of the hour who are you
putting down oh you don't know her
who is it your mom
yeah whatever
look at that
I have recently taken a lover well
that's great congratulations
who's the lucky lady Pam's mom
what Pam's mom Helene remember from your
wedding
you're messing with me about what you
did not have sex with Pam's mom oh big
time what kind of cars to drive she
drives a green camera and the seats go
all the way down
all the way down oh my God
Stanley Hudson
you are fired
are you serious
I am serious we are all serious
you are fired like a heart attack
oh come on it's not real family no no no
no no no you will not die Stanley
Stanley you will not die sadly Stanley
Barack is President you are black sadly
I want to give her mouth about no no
don't give a mouth to mouth for this
Michael so I don't follow him
save me
oh no gifts for you
I hate to even ask because you've been
so accommodating about all the women
your wish is my command
is there any way our first dance can be
to my favorite song
The Little Drummer Boy
of course
really yeah who's that
oh it's just my avatar guy whatever
a lot like you
did you spend not much
it's just for tracking Dwight so right
you're a sports writer in Philadelphia
nice build too
yeah you have a guitar slung on your
back I did not know you played guitar
why don't we go back to the
ah show me how this works
all right I'm taking off
booty call nope just going to see Pam
baby put up some shelves wait a second
I don't want you to end up
the surprise pregnancy like me okay
thank you for this you want more no
foreign
hey Dwight uh
send in the subs
oh
I'm friends with everybody in this
office we're all best friends we I love
everybody here but sometimes your best
friends
start coming into work late and start
having dentist appointments that aren't
dentist appointments
I'm going to the dentist okay
I have to have an emergency Crown put in
ouch yes
it's a new dentist
he's far I might be gone
three hours
three hours Wow have fun
hey device hey you want an Eminem no
thanks I'm stuffed no seriously
should have an m m they're really good
okay
good huh
oh God
hey I thought you weren't supposed to
eat anything for a couple of hours after
you've had a crowd put in
having this new kind of quick drying
bonding
ah sounds like a good dentist oh yeah
oh yeah what's his name
crentist
your dentist name is krentist
huh
sounds a lot like dentist
maybe that's why he became a dentist
your teeth
let me see him let me see him
oh
you should floss them my God
there is a hardwood floor underneath
this carpeting why would they do that
one two three
oh and we have torn up the cob Hill
we're gonna be in so much trouble wait
it's beautiful Hardwood
I always knew it was down here I just
never dreamed that I would actually see
it